Malawi
well we now have some breaking news the
international criminal court and the
Hague has issued an arrest warrant for
Russian President Vladimir Putin in a
statement the ICC said the warrant is in
connection with allegations of war
crimes in Ukraine and the court is also
issued a warrant to arrest Maria lavova
belova she is Russia's presidential
commissioner for children's rights
Moscow has repeatedly denied accusations
of atrocities during the one-year
conflict
today 17th of March 2023
the international criminal court has
issued Two Worlds of arrest in the
Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian president
from children's right for the alleged
war crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories
entered the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories children enjoy special
protection under the Geneva Convention
the contents of the worlds are secret in
order to protect victims the ICC
attaches great importance to the
protection of victims especially
children
nevertheless the judges of The Chamber
are dealing with this case decided to
make the existence of the world's public
in the interests of justice and to
prevent the commission of future crimes
this is an important moment in the
process of Justice before the ICC the
judges have revealed the information and
evidence submitted by the prosecutor and
determined that there are credible
allegations against these persons for
the alleged crimes
the ICC is doing its part of work
as a court of law the judges issued
arrest warrants the execution depends on
International cooperation
well meanwhile Russia has